thank you so very much for being here um
and um for being the stalk
so
the the plan i have with my talk uh can
you read the slides first of all
thank you um the plan i have with my
talk is ask this one let's try to make
it working right so the agenda i had in
mind was
uh to introduce a little bit uh what
five script is and what by script is not
um
and talk about a little bit of pie
script from a deep science perspective
and to to be fair what you'll see in the
slides is also coming up from all the
wonderful conversation i've had in this
couple of days with some of you
and in the last bits it's going to be
demo time specifically talking about
digitalization uh first of all has
anyone here tried by script already
good so not many of you okay so and and
do you know already what five script is
or do you have a guess of what price
group might be
okay fantastic so um
first of all
please be advised pi script is still an
in the alpha version under heavy
development uh so there may be issues
there are no well known issues
reusability loading times and so you
should not expect to use that in
production and things may change often
and and so this is one another reason
why i do believe this is a great time to
have a talk about pi script because we
we need to to get the community on board
and see
what can things can be
what things can be done with by script
and so
be ready that sometimes things can go
really bad
um
this is because as i said it's a work in
progress under every development and
in fact another thing i hope to just to
showcase to you is the things i wanted
to include in the examples i
um i made but didn't work all the things
i found out along the way and in fact it
was kind of a my face when i was
preparing this light like i wasn't sure
if i fixed it or if it was totally
broken anyway um so what spy script is
first of all
pi script looks like that it's a an html
including um it's a bit of dark isn't it
it's an html um
showing
this pie script tag in which you can
actually include python code
and
if i'm being honest with you the very
first time i saw this project actually
in a in a preview stage
i had
good php right
it was like um
interesting
um and and that actually reminded me of
um and we have to be honest first of all
we know that we as pythonistas were very
kind opinionated people about php
and
that's a good one and um
and also
we all know that
there's just one rule in the rule book
of php it's just like use something else
um
but to be
completely honest uh the the thing i
also remembered was kind of you know
coding and the browser and it reminds me
of i don't know who who here has ever
used the jsp in the past i don't know
this is really a test and url on your
age at the moment um
yeah i'm not i'm that old and i do
remember
the vibes of writing javascript page the
thing is
it's it's it it's totally not
despite in my look like that it's
totally not
and there's a good reason why that um
i'm saying this
and if you know what i'm talking about
if you know
several pages this jsp thing um you can
probably remember the struggle in
setting up the web server the tomcat
engine and all the infrastructure you
need to have this code running in the
browser there was a huge stack of
software putting putting the things all
together just to run a dynamic web page
that was
totally useless but it's it was
it was actually the starting of very
good things in software and in fact
when you used to write our code in the
browser
the the follow-up of these kind of
technologies
was what we now call frameworks now we
are so used to
web frameworks like django django is
i've been using django since version
0.96 now we have a django 4. and so lots
lots happened and then
there were lots of discussion back then
as in if if that were
ever made to the to you know to the
enterprise
and uh so you have to think that that
was the age in which python was not so
mainstream as it is today and and so um
the the these idea of bringing code in
the html and so melting up all together
like the model the view the controller
everything there was was exactly what we
wanted to run away from and so
development web framework were born
and so it seems like we we're going back
to that and and and and to some extent
might look like that and i i do
understand why
but the reason why i'm putting this
memes here is because i want to
highlight which is uh the thing this is
actually not happening
and there's also another bit i found
this on twitter and
i've read around things like people
saying oh cool now we can run python in
the browser we don't need javascript at
all
and uh i want to stress this very
clearly this is certainly not the case
pi script has not been developed to
replace javascript and is not a drop-in
replacement for javascript it's quite
the opposite actually
pyscript loves javascript and
and if anything one thing we can say
is that
pyscript
helps a lot integrating the two worlds
as in python and javascript and
the reason why i'm saying this is
because javascript is we all know is
it's kind of a difficult language to
deal with you you hate it to love it
it's there's no way or other way around
but um
python is so crucial in the data science
and so imagine what you can do
if you actually bring
these two words together
and this is also another reason why
we're talking about digitization india
um
pi um pyscript loves javascript um
because of pyodide so pyodide is what is
doing the heavy heavy work
and um
it allows execution of python over
wasm
it brings the full pi data stack already
into
into the environment and it gives you
direct access to the dom and the
manipulation of the dom manipulation
objects the things you were used to do
in in javascript normally but now you
can implement this in python and so you
can
you always if you're starting to if you
if you get your bearings into
into pi script the things you will end
up doing most of the time is from iodide
import create proxy fetch open url
there's some very useful utility
functions or something like from js
import document we're going to see
examples for that later on
and so
to conclude this bit what is javascript
in the end uh sorry pi script in the end
pi script is a framework that allows
users to create reach python
applications
that runs in the browser using html
interface
the framework uses
provides users at every experience level
with access to an expressive easy to
learn programming language with
countless application and in fact the
mission and the vision of pi script is
as you can see on the website is bring
bringing programming for the 99
this is an unimportant
aspect we should probably talk about
later
um
in conclusion and very in in summary
pi script is python in the browser
it's a python ecosystem running in the
browser so you can run many popular
packages of python in scientific python
stack
and is a bi-directional channel to
communicate between python and
javascript
it's also and this is a one of the the
feature i like very much is is is a
great tool to handle environments
and this is going to be important for
the paid the pi data and data science
bit
and it also includes this is actually
very interesting
also includes visual visual application
development so includes um in the api
some components you can use to to create
some ui components in the browser like
buttons or text inputs and and and
things like that
we all developers so
probably the the second thing i did um
when i started working with pi scripting
was
seeing if there was any integration with
id
i'm happy to report that pychan
is is including uh in the early access
program version of the 2022 version 0.2
i think um and uh uh an initial support
for five trips actually it's quite it's
quite robust and this is the editor uh
sorry the ide i'm using i will be using
later to showcase the
um
the examples
fyi for those of you using vs code there
is a plug-in
but not exactly working properly at the
moment so i don't recommend it there's a
lot of issues with that especially
because it's
it's reformatting the code normally
automatically you have to disable it in
visual through the code and this can
create issues when you're working with
um
the the pi script part of python
which is still something you have to you
have to take care of
um
so why developing pi script well of
course why not and um
pi script um more seriously why pisce
script is so important from a deep
science perspective in my opinion
um
first of all
something you have to think about is
whenever you have python running in the
browser you're essentially
changing completely the perspective of
enviro environment computation in in
data science we're so used of thinking
about reducibility as a synonym
sometimes
or most of the time as a synonym a
synonym for docker so we have docker to
do everything and so we think in terms
of docker content containers and so we
have to set up a docker container which
is not a very lightweight thing to deal
with
um
with just one purpose in mind sharing an
environment because what we do care
about in terms of reproducibility is i
want to guarantee you that you're going
to use
more or less the same enviro the same
competition environment you've been
using so far and this goes to
to the extent of
packages and package versions
but of course to do that you need a lot
of infrastructure
what if instead
we could use
web browsers as ubiquitous virtual
machines
so an
ubiquitous engine
in which on one hand
you have
all the security requirements already
guaranteed for you because it's a web
browser
and on the other end
you do have an environment that allows
you to
to be on
whichever machine with no installation
required and no environment required
i want to stress this out because this
is one of the main features i like the
most in pi script
you don't need python on your machine to
run pyscript
and this is outstanding in my opinion it
thing it brings things to a different
level
and why no environment actually the
environment can be handled and it's
self-contained so pyscript this this is
why i stressed out that earlier pyscript
um
is it is a thing what it is really is a
theme framework which sits on top of pi
died pioud is doing the heavy job as i
said but pie scripts puts the things on
top that pilot is missing because
actually it's out of the scope of the
project iodide is bringing python to
wasn't
uh pi yes python pyscript on the other
hand is is is making what is necessary
to bring this kind of technology
to the data science world
in a in in a way which is
um which is going towards what data
science needs and as i said probably one
of the first thing we we might need is
how do we share an environment and pi
script has a component which is called
pyenv to do what you need
to set up your environment
you can add rapple and this is what we
like
in this science we're so used to jupiter
that we want to add rep we can add
rapple to web pages and so for example
we can have components like this this is
a rapple i know if you can see that
clearly
but i can type in this thing
so this is a rebel i can
type import this
i can run it and i get the result
directly into
the browser
i can
import anti-gravity
because in python we know we love pans
and things like that do you know what
input anti-gravity does normally
no
cool so when you're important and this
is actually something i i do
highly recommend you to do normally in
your ipython browser you when you import
anti-gravity
uh it links to this oh i'm sorry this
doesn't it's not really clear um
uh you
have uh this xkcd
um
i promise you my screen is way better
i'm sorry
you have this xkcd comic
but the interesting bit in in pi script
and so the power of bringing python to
the web browser is when you do something
like antigravity.fly
whoops
and
that's my bed
there you go
now you make it flying really
so
um
enough with the chitchat
and
yeah this is one of my favorite uh let's
go with the demo um we can do some
actually
before moving to the data visualization
bit uh this is the the very last example
of on red pool you can actually have
serious code
whatever serious means um
running here in the browser so i can run
it
and
it takes a little bit because
performance is still an issue at the
moment just be advised and you can
generate from this code the actual
output so this is simulating what you
can the experience of a jupiter notebook
so you have a repo and
an html div in which you put the output
and i'll show you in a second how can
you actually do this how simple is that
it's very interesting you have to
remember that um let me see what's next
okay data this time um let me now move
to the
to the code first
oh this goes later
right okay first off
can you read the code probably not
just
try me try to what's the
all right
okay so what you need to have it set up
it's it's an html file this is hello
world so
um
what you have to do is to include pi
script.css and pyscript.js the css is
actually needed for the the com the ui
components
and all you need to do is to import this
javascript uh file which is from which
is called piscrib.js and you're ready to
go
uh in this particular case what we're
doing here
is we creating a new script which is
called pi script and in case you're
wondering
uh why the dashing it's it's because um
this is in in accordance to the
specification of the web whenever you
have to make a new
uh html tag
it has to contain hyphens in the names
and so that is why pi script uh so as
you can see here well i can probably do
better like highlighting here this is
python code and so we are running this
python code into this pi script tag
environment
and this is what we get so just to
clarify
i'm going to show you
refreshing this
and this is what we get so now we have
date and time
calculated in python okay
so let's move on to something more
interesting which is
um
first thing of course in in data
visualization is how do we do we make it
uh working with matlab flip
map my lip um is very easy
and there's the first i want to showcase
there's very few things to say about it
but one thing i'm going to show you
essentially
um
the main the first feature i want to
show you is
whenever you can specify what is the
output
the destination of the output
um
in this particular case is the id of the
div
where you want to put the output of the
computation and you can do that by
saying output equal to the id of the of
the items you want
which is this one just on top
so when we run this this code the output
of this code is going to be into this
this item here
what i'm going to show you here is is a
simple example in which you have
matlab lib running into the browser okay
this is normally normal matlab lip
another thing you you may want to do if
you want to improve the the rendering of
the visualization you can use a
different
uh back end for maple lip which is html5
i've discovered this looking at the
um uh pyrite blog post kind of thing i
found it on the web and as you can see
there's a huge difference in terms of i
don't know if you can actually see it
but when you run it on your computer you
can
totally see the difference from from the
well of course this is an image this is
an interactive thing
uh and the same time the the rendering
of the of the font is is better to do
that you have to essentially load this
module into multiple label and use it as
as the
back end the rendering back end the code
is exactly the same
um
feel free to interrupt if you have any
questions by the way no no worries at
all
so
now the
my journey into this uh for you is going
to be like in
improving or changing the technologies
so that we're going towards
understanding
what is the potential
of things that we can do
at the same time
how easy is to code these things because
it's important to this is one of the one
another feature we should always keep in
mind because let's face it data
visualization
done
let me not properly but done it in the
javascript way
is is cumbersome for us python is this
because the api is not familiar
is not very you know um
close to what we used to in python and
so in the python ecosystem by the way
we've had lots of lots of projects super
interesting ones which are aiming
towards
towards having this you know
api simplification as much as possible
so that we can we have easy to tools
that we can easily use in python
which will do the heavy job of
translating things into javascript
and probably the first uh in in in the
series is bokeh has anyone ever used
bokeh here
yeah this is around for many years and
bokeh was was amazing
when it was released because essentially
was the the very first
um interactive plotting library in
python it was is is like python api
translating everything into
into javascript objects and and nowadays
that
data science is moving at the pace of
apis
um tools like this are amazing because
they easily integrate
apis talking in javascript and json and
so you can actually
embed um
you can return plots from an api using
using vocab and so that was what we did
long time ago but that was actually one
of the potentials of twos like that and
so why is him
another reason why it's so important
integrating bokeh is is as easy as you
can see
and and code wise
is easy as well and this gives me the
opportunity to bring on the attention on
one feature i
overlooked before which is the
environment thing i i mentioned before
in in
in in pyscript you can specify what is
the environment you need
into
the the page
which automatically so
technologically speaking it works like
that so pyodide includes the the pi data
stack
uh but
loading all the stack in memory would be
useless if you don't need it
uh so what you normally do is
you load it using javascript or
uh through pyour diet
what pi script is doing for you using
the pi amp is that you can you can
specify a yaml
version of your environment
saying what are the packages you need
and these will will be
brought into the namespace and memory
whenever you need it
simple as that
if you if you see the equivalent um
the the instructions to do this in in pi
in pio died is is way more complicated
because it's using different tools in
the in the
in the back end
um
there's also another bit this paem
um
tag
has lots of um
interesting features lots of perks
uh you you can bring on in your
environment
uh the packages pi that already includes
but you can also include in your package
um
sorry in your environment
any
python pure python package you can
install from pip
so you can specify instead of a name you
can specify the url of a wheel of python
and that will be installed and bring
brought into your environment
automatically
and again this is all running into your
browser i'll show you example later on
about this
last but not least
you can actually also load
modules from your local domain
so you essentially have everything you
need
and
um this will be the next next example so
this is using
full-fledged feature of pi script with
pyev we do need just bokeh and numpy in
this code and in fact this is the code
we need
the only thing to highlight in this code
probably is that since bookcare is is
talking javascript in the end um the way
in which you can inter-integrate
um
bokeh plots into
the um
you you can return the bokeh plot as a
json as a javascript object directly
using the bokeh api and this will go
automatically into the div you want to
to
write to
the rest of it is simple a scene
function using numpy not nothing
particularly fancy
to make things actually fancier
what i did was was moving into
making an interactive plot in in bokeh
so we we're so used to interactivity
with bokeh that we we
we normally expect something of that so
a much more comp and rich and more
complicated dashboard so i'm using the
mpg um
auto mpg data set including the bokeh
sample data
and i'm going to show you how can you
actually generate different plots so
now i am interacting with widgets
generated by bokeh this is pure pocket
bokeh code
and i'm going to
change different settings and so the
plotting will be automatically updated
so what i'm doing is essentially
bringing what i normally go
in writing into python applications
or jupyter notebooks but this time
everything goes into a simple html file
simple like in quotes i would say simple
because it's rich in terms of what it
contains but it's simple in terms of
data format
and
this goes like that and i can keep on
going at the same time you do have all
the interactivity you you would expect
from using a bokeh plot here this is an
over tool uh which is this one i can
disable as you can see and this is a
zoom bit you can use this is a normal
bokeh plot
okay um
moving on um
alter is another is not interesting this
is a data visualization package um ulta
is interesting because it's it's
tackling the problem of data
visualization from a different
perspective alter is a is a python
api on top of viega which is a
um i would say it's a declarative data
visualization tool um which is
essentially tries to
write describe a to a a chart in a in a
json manner and and so you can write uh
the the the the the
uh details of this tool uh and and an
alter is is bringing the python api on
top of it and um what i'm doing in this
example
is
showcasing how you can actually load a
local file because all the coding here
is living into a separate module
which is called
alter charts.pi
and so another another attribute i'm
showcasing here pi script is the source
um
attribute so you can load the content of
a pi script snippet
from a separate file which is this one
and so it lives locally
on my computer
and
this also brings
[Music]
so ulta a pandas
i can't remember exactly
whether alter or is it already included
or not into
pyodide uh vega dates sets probably not
so this will be installed uh i'm going
by memory to be fair so i
might probably be wrong
this also brings on another important
aspect of things
altered charts dot pi is a file living
locally
which means
you can have access to the file system
but there's a big but you you can
you you cannot do that
in a in a static web page you need to
run this web page in a web server
because otherwise you'll be violating
course policy and so you cannot do that
it's it's impossible to do that so
this will bring to a different
discussion maybe if we have time in the
end we can we can talk about it but the
point is
[Music]
you have to serve this page
in a web server so what i'm doing right
now is like using the simple http server
uh from python uh or as as we saw
yesterday in the lightning talks for
those of you here this could normally go
into a github page on a github
repository which is actually where this
is going to be in the end
i'll share the link on slack when i'll
put everything there
let's move on this is taken from the uh
examples you find already into
um
the set of examples in pi script this is
showcasing how you can use volume volume
is a wonderful tool to work with map
and what we saw here is the
interactivity integrated into the
browser and
probably one of the most important
things to highlight here is that all the
computation is running on the client
side and this also goes for another
example and something we saw yesterday
already again in the lighting talks but
the the most important bit to stress out
is
you have to remember that since
everything lives in the client side
you don't have
you you cut off all the lug and
the overhead you might have when you
have api communication back and forth
from the back end to the front end and
vice versa
what i want to show you
instead of the actual output here in
volume is how easy to work with these
things so here's the actual code so what
we're doing is
we
load the data from a url
using standard pandas
the only the only bit to remember is
that we open the url using iodide
uh then we convert it in in g in in json
object
we pass it to a volume up
um
object
then we create
uh the coral flat on on the on the map
and then we
add it to the layer control and that's
it so this few lines of code are
generating that visualization there's no
more than that i promise this is the
only code i needed and volume is the div
in which everything leaves
so as you can see we can have effective
data visualization results in a very few
lines of code and this is also the case
that brings on the next tool i want to
highlight which is hv plot
h3 plot is is a wonderful tool which is
this is trying to
take the best of many worlds in
particular is integrating uh perfectly
with bulkhead with the whole views with
other shaders which is automatically
choosing uh the right backhand depending
on the amount of data you have
this is just to this is a simple plot to
showcase that actually hp plot works and
the reason why i'm telling you this is
because this goes into the
cumbersome at the moment but soon not
two
examples i want to highlight
there's a huge shout out to uh to philip
um core developer of um uh philip
rudiger who gave me we worked together
on this um
the other day um
and
it goes like that
so essentially there was a there was a
little issue that will be probably soon
fixed in pio died
which didn't allow
uh in pio died to install package in a
pre-released version
this is what i told you this this is in
under active development so you have to
work with these things um this is to
showcase how you can actually import a
will
and
with a full url
but this will is a pre-release of all of
use because all of use is getting there
into supporting fully pi script at the
moment is in pre-release but pyodide
didn't like a pre-release package into
that and so the way we worked around
that was using micropip which is the
package manager including pio died to
work to install these things
automatically and to fool it by saying
the version that we have it is the
1.15.0
and
and there you go so this this sort of a
hackish solution made the things working
and most importantly the reason why
i wanted to do this is because i want to
showcase the next example which is
integrating
um
that's not the one
the one i wanted is
there you go this is integration with
hvplot and panel which is the last tool
of the list i wanted to highlight
the code as simple as that and that's
why i'm telling you this so here's the
hackish solution again
we include panel and
look at how simple is is that so panel
brings in
we had the lighting talks yesterday
look at it the project is amazing is
bringing easy
ways and an intuitive python api to
write um
[Music]
rich
interactive applications
in this case they're running into the
browser thanks to pyscript
and we are creating the widgets here
which is a panel column including the
select origin as a cylinder which are
another two widgets provided by panel
and
this function thanks to hv plot is
essentially the function that controls
these widgets so
or the other way around this function is
controlled by the widgets so
with this
four lines of
code we have created this simple
application which is
having the widget taken the data from a
data data frame
and an interactive plot we can play with
it's just three lines of code
and so
for those of you thinking well if you
instead of bringing python
to the to the web to not write
javascript let's learn javascript and
that's it
this is why i'm telling you this there's
no way you can do so easy
um
things like this into javascript so if
the api is different so
this is another reason why thank you
another reason why uh pi script is so
crucial in this in these things
um
so in the interest of time i just want
to highlight
um the other example i have and you'll
find there
will be be taking more rich examples of
things you can do uh this is panel uh on
a penguin state set so this is way
richer i just showcase things here so
you can interact this widget uh you can
change this is a k-means clustering
running you can reduce a number of
clusters uh the interesting bit here is
that you can select
data from here and having that the table
updated um automatically so this is the
way richer example than what i've done
so far
um i just oh this is a streaming demo
this is absolutely interesting probably
something similar shown in the lighting
talk yesterday again taken from the set
of example already available available
in pi script
um i want to
uh conclude with three things actually
so the first is something we found out
the other day
so uh the the this example is really
ugly actually it's unfinished but it's
it's more what's what's behind that i
want to talk about
what i really wanted to do since you can
bring all the pi data stack the main pi
data stack into the browser cycle learn
included uh we wanted to i wanted to
showcase digits they'd set tsne
dimension reduction result
long story short
let me show the case the code
long story short we um it was me and
young the match
core developer of cycle learn
and
we realized that if you
if you don't pass in this so apparently
internally and this is a discussion they
were having as i learned at the same
time
probably a couple of weeks ago the tsne
implementation is is doing some
numerical optimization for memory
consumption so if you pass in float 64
numbers sorry sorry num uh integer 64
numbers like i was doing uh which is the
default uh data type uh secondary
internally makes it in integer 32 for of
course because if you don't need that
precision you reduce memory and so
competition is faster but apparently pi
and i didn't like
integer 32 and so this example didn't
work so to make this working we had
essentially two communities bringing
together effort into understanding what
was going on and the reason why i'm
telling you this is because
um
the
another reason why i i was so happy to
do this talk is because at this stage
pi script is probably community as well
in the features that we want to list
because of the pi pi script is is is
becoming
the
connector the you know the funnel of
many communities bringing together into
what is potentially being the the
platform or competition for data science
of the future which is the browser
finally
and so this is actually a very
interesting example i want to showcase
and so to fix this i had to make a pca
first and pass in because if you pass
the initialization vector to t as an
etsn is not doing any any any mess with
your data type
if it's randomly initialized it does
conversion and so pi doesn't like it
the reason why i ended up doing the
bench reduction is because i wanted to
showcase something quite new as in let's
try umap has anyone ever used umap
so umap internally uses number to make
computation going very fast the number
is is jit compile and runs on llvm
which is not wasn't and so
number at the moment is not yet
supported by pyodide but i just want to
show the issue
that they're actually working on it uh
no this that's philip
um the issue i want to yes there you go
there's this uh open on the second of
may this year so again this is super
active development uh in in in number
uh they're working on this and so
probably
uh the um
number on
um
wasm and so fired identity prescript
might be a thing in the near future
last but not least
in in in the list of demo
i want to highlight the demo of all
demos
this live show
i made light show using pi script
and how i did it hmm
glad i am glad you asked um
even if you didn't um
[Music]
actually is it's as simple as that so i
have this slides
html
and the slides in html is including
first off
well
the path of local files anti-gravity i
showed you before
but more importantly is creating a
widget
thanks to pi script
so i've created this slides.pi
um which is this component has been
registered as a widget and what i
actually actually is not my work this is
fabio's work um i'm
fixed these and that but essentially is
his work um for presented as in the
keynote of pike in italia to be fair
and um
the the cool bits of this is that slides
are actually made is
super super ackey but it's a texture
file so it's a textual slash html file
and so the slides you're seeing here is
like
created automatically and and generated
automatically apply script so
and in fact you can i can give it away
by
doing something like no that's not one
something like that so if i refresh this
pi script codes gets loaded i am not
going to do this because i just want to
wrap up and thank you so very much for
the stalk
thank you very much valerio right we
have time for one question that was
super quick oh there we go i'm going to
take that one in the back just in the
interest
time around
change
of
here we go
[Music]
hi hi um
what what are the
limits on memory and cpu applied on pi
script like is is chrome doing that or
is biodyne doing that behind or right
that's a very good question so first off
something i should say timescript at the
moment as far as i know has been tested
just in chrome that's why i'm using
chrome so
things may may be different on other
browsers
at the moment performance issues is a
thing so it's you you have to expect a
little bit of delay in terms of
computation especially when you run
things
you don't have to you
there's no buffered output for example
at the moment so if you do the printing
that's gonna appear in the end when the
competition has ended um
and
the um as far as i know they com the the
limits of competition is is is a pioneer
level and so
what's happened to me was sometimes that
the browser complained and saying this
page is taking too long do you want to
kill it or do you want to wait but
honestly it's uh one way to circumvent
this would be to
to in to save some time in memory you
can download pi script locally and load
it or build it locally or
load it locally rather than the api that
saves time a little bit
[Music]
this is why what i know at the moment
lovely thank you very thank you for the
ariel thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you